ahora ya sabemos que podemos ver las
fracciones como división es decir que si
yo tengo por ejemplo 22 a esto lo divido
lo divido entre 9 esto es exactamente lo
mismo es exactamente lo mismo que decir
22 entre 9 entre 9 y lo padre es que
ahora puedo ver a las fracciones dos
novenos como una división como 2 entre 9
el numerador entre el denominador de
igual manera por ejemplo si yo me tomo
77 y lo divido y lo divido entre 7 bueno
pues esto es exactamente lo mismo
déjame cambiar a este color esto es
exactamente lo mismo que tomarme 7 y al
7 poderlo dividir poderlo dividir entre
7 entre 7 y bueno 7 entre 7 eso sabemos
cuánto es esto es exactamente lo mismo
es decir que 7 séptimos es lo mismo que
1 que bueno eso ya lo sabíamos porque
habíamos dicho que siempre que
tuviéramos el numerador y el denominador
iguales
ok bueno y podemos seguir viendo
ejemplos ahora si me tomo por ejemplo
1818 y lo divido y lo divide en 36 de
igual manera puedo decir que esto es
exactamente lo mismo que 1818 dividido
18 entre 6 dividido entre 6 lo cual por
cierto es exacto 18 entre 6 es
exactamente lo mismo que 318 entre 6
estrés y por lo tanto 18 sextos
es lo mismo que 3 si nosotros lo vemos
con una división 18 sextos
es lo mismo que 18 entre 6 lo cual es 33
enteros y es que tú lo puedes ver la
siguiente manera déjame ponerlo así 18
18 lo voy a dividir lo voy a dividir
entre 6 entre 6 y esto es exactamente lo
mismo y esto es exactamente lo mismo
para que tú lo entiendas mejor que
tomarme
+ 6 + 6 ok 666 1.018 666 / todo / todo
entre 6 ok y bueno lo padre es que esto
es exactamente lo mismo que tomarme am
de capturarlo con este color
6 / / 6 ok
6 más
otra vez 6 en 36 más 6 entre 6 aunque
entre 6 ya esto espera déjame ponerlo
con el mismo color ya esto a sumarle 6
en 36 ya esto es un mar lo otra vez 66
entre 66 entre 6 y bueno como nosotros
hemos visto 6 entre 6 sabemos que esto
se va a 1 porque sabemos que un número
dividido entre sí mismo es lo mismo que
uno por lo tanto este de aquí se va a 1
este equipo se va a 1 y este de aquí
también se va a 16 en 366 entre 6 + 6 en
36 es uno que uno más uno más uno que es
lo mismo que tres que tres enteros y
bueno aquí está la forma de entenderlo
de una manera mucho más tranquila y más
analizada lo que estoy haciendo es
descomponiendo al 18 en 36 como 6 + 6 +
6 todo eso entre 6 y bueno
me doy cuenta que esto es lo mismo que
tres enteros ahora todo ha salido bien
hasta ahorita porque nos hemos dado
cuenta que estamos trabajando con puros
números enteros es decir cuando nos
tomamos el numerador que es
completamente divisible entre el
denominador ahora qué pasa si nos
tomamos un número que no sea divisible
de manera exacta entre el numerador se
me ocurre por ejemplo al tomarme 23-23
ya esto lo voy a dividir lo voy a
dividir entre 6 ok bueno si me tomo 23
sextos esto es exactamente lo mismo y
justo por lo que acabamos de ver que 23
que 23 dividido dividido entre 6 23
entre 6 ok y aquí tenemos una división
que podemos realizar de una manera muy
sencilla justo por aquí esto es lo mismo
que tomarme 23 23 y dividirlo y
dividirlo en 36 y bueno 6 cabe tres
veces en veintitrés por lo tanto pondré
aquí 3
3 por 6 es 18 le quito 18 y cuando yo me
tomo la resta de estos 2 me va a quedar
23 menos 18 en lo cual es 5 por lo tanto
estoy diciendo que 23 entre 6 y déjame
ponerlo de nuevo acá 23 23
entre 6 entre 6 han visto de una manera
tal vez un poco ti diana podemos decir
que esto es exactamente lo mismo que 3
enteros y tener un residuo de 5 o dicho
otra manera
5 residuo 35 residuo 3 ok
3 enteros y tenemos un residuo de 5
bueno ahora si nos fijamos a esta
fracción 23 entre 6 no puedo poner que
esto es sin corregido 3 no tiene con que
mucha lógica por lo tanto lo que se
utiliza casi siempre es expresar el 23
como algo que se pueda dividir entre 6
más nuestro residuo es decir que el 23
23 entre 6 entre 6 lo puedo visualizar
siguiendo esta lógica de aquí común y
esto es exactamente lo mismo que 18 18
55 entre 65 todo esto dividido entre 6
ok
date cuenta que el 18 más 5 23 y tengo
el mismo denominador por lo tanto 23
sextos es lo mismo que el 18 más 5 entre
6 y bueno justo por lo que acabamos de
ver aquí arriba esto es exactamente lo
mismo que tomarme 18 18 entre 6 entre 6
ok más +5 entre 6 + 5 entre 6 entre 6 ok
del lujo ahora quiero que te des cuenta
que lo padre de todo esto es que sabemos
cuánto es distinto en 3 618 en 36 esto
es 3 y lo acabamos de ver justo acá
arriba 18 entre
6 estrés que es lo mismo que 18 sextos
entonces aquí tengo 3 enteros más 5
sextos lo cual es un número mixto cuando
tengo una parte entera y otra parte en
fracción estoy hablando de un número
mixto y entonces podemos decir que 23
sobre 6 que es una fracción impropia es
una fracción de impropia porque el de
arriba es más grande que el de abajo
esta fracción impropia la podemos
escribir como un número mixto de la
siguiente manera y para eso déjame bajar
un poco la pantalla déjenme bajar un
poco la pantalla ok y entonces quiero
que veas que 23 entre 6 lo puedo
visualizar lo puedo visualizar como
déjame poner este color como 3 más
5 sobre 6 + 5 sobre 6 5 sobre 6 lo cual
es exactamente lo mismo lo cual es
exactamente lo mismo que 3 enteros que 3
enteros 5 5 sextos 5 sobre 6 y está de
lujo 23 sobre 6 lo puedo ver como un
numero mixto como 3 enteros 5 sextos y
eso es lo que quería contarte en este
vídeo ahora podemos ver a las fracciones
impropias como números mixtos si lo que
hacemos es dividir el numerador entre el
denominador justo viendo una fracción
como división